alors moi je pense qu'on n'a pas faut
pas qu'on vivre dans la peur il faut pas
qu'on cède à la peur et on n'appréhende
les rues comme étant des obstacles sur
notre voie là sur notre chemin sur notre
manière de déambuler donc c'est pour ça
que je dis non il ne faut pas avoir peur
il faut évidemment tenir compte de ce
qui se passe et je suis très sensible à
ce que vous avez vécu parce que il ya
l'or va nous raconter luan lorsqu'elle
avait voulu voix et je moi y'a quelques
quelques quelques semaines jarre quand
je marchais dans la rue j'ai été aussi
menacé par un homme et j'ai dû me
réfugier ce qui s'est passé a raconté le
fait qu'un homme qui me suit qui a
commencé à me suivre me demander mon nom
numéro de téléphone et j'ai refusé de le
faire qu'en fait il m'a menacé de
m'agresser et j'ai dû me réfugier dans
une boutique
il a attendu dehors en fait en me disant
toutes les façons moi j'ai pas d'endroit
où dormir non si je suis en garde à vue
aucun problème effectivement j'ai eu
peur je veux dire dehors et c'est vrai
mais c'est au milieu de la journée il
était 13h donc j'étais pas je n'étais
pas à l'aise
toutefois moi je veux pas céder je veux
pas céder à ça je veux pas que la rue ne
m'appartiennent plus parce qu'un homme a
décidé que je devais lui donner mon
numéro de téléphone ça services étaient
déjà arrivés au sap à ce niveau là je
pense qu'il ya énormément de tensions en
ce moment c'est ça ce que je crois c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de tensions mais ce
que je déplore c'est que les
personnalités politiques utilisent cette
tension utilisent cette peur pour une
certaine manière à ces mots les termes
comme en sauvagement qui ne font que
jeter de l'huile sur le feu sans
apporter des solutions concrètes je
trouve que c'est un problème et je pense
que au lieu d'apporter des réponses
concrètes
en fait ils ne font que donner de grain
à moudre pour compte pour qu'on débatte
pour qu'on débatte source est le
titulaire on expliquer aux gens que ce
qu'il voyait
il ne le voyais pas aussi subissent ils
ne subissait pas cessé leur jeu mais
après six mois une permanence en
cylindrée de centimes le lac est
lassante la question sentiment
d'insécurité je pense que c'est un mot
qui est juste parce que je crois aussi
qu'on est dans une ère de surinformation
joie des images auxquelles on assiste
on n'aurait jamais vu auparavant cook
est ce que disait bruno pomart te leur
disait il y avait des choses qui se
passaient mais les réseaux sociaux
solidement ont mis en exergue des choses
qu'on voyait pas avant je pense qu il
est policier qu'il est plus à même de
nous dire que des choses atroces se
passait auparavant mais on n'avait pas
la technologie que ça manquait donc où
tout le monde a peur mais parce qu ici
on voit des choses qu'on ne pouvait pas
voir parade renault voulait réagir m'a
coupé le jeu reprendra près d'accord je
vous appelle milieu de semaine prochaine
non mais agassa gâteau pour qu'ils
financent homme violent trois ans en
plus on peut me dire que c'est seulement
avec ces chiffres c'est long mais je
suis désolé moi je pense que si on nie
la réalité ça va être encore pire c'est
pas mettre de l'huile sur le feu que de
dénoncer les chaussées les kabyles et
d'agresser quelqu'un sait pas où on a
dix ans sauvagement qui ne va pas
agresser quelqu'un
agata pandora bruno gaccio mais c'est
très intéressant que tu prennes ce
chiffre là moi je pense j'ai répondu non
à cette question parce que comme rokhaya
comme malek je pense pas qu'on doive
sortir dans la rue la peur au ventre et
je pense pas qu'on doive se dit oh mon
dieu je suis en train de sortir de chez
moi je peux me faire agresser à tout
moment je pense qu'il faut qu'on qu'on
reste maître de nos émotions qu'on ne
cède pas ce climat anxiogène
il ya eu plein de trucs cet été un peu
bizarre il ya un restaurant à casser une
pile d'assiettes et les gens pensaient
que c'était un coup de feu il ya eu un
mouvement de panique
affreux on est tous très tendus très
nerveux pour plein de raisons
je pense qu'il faut plutôt essayer de
s'apaiser et allait dans ce sens là mais
quand tu parles des chiffres laurence et
qu'on les prend comme ça les chiffres
eux seuls n'ont aucun intérêt parce
qu'ils sont à remettre dans un contexte
structurel de société beaucoup plus
globale effectivement on nous annonce
que à longueur de journée que les viols
les agressions augmentent
substantiellement depuis 10 30 ans met
d'accord ça peut être dû à une réelle
montée de la violence réelle montée de
l'insécurité
sauf que c'est peut-être dû aussi à une
évolution des médias à l'évolution du
traitement médiatique de ces choses là
ça peut être lui aussi un durcissement
de la loi depuis les dix dernières
années c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
les victimes de porter plainte
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour les
plains d'être recensé les forces de
police sont ont des recours plus
simplifié pour les prendre en compte et
ça ajoute des chiffres aux statistiques
il ya tout ça aussi il faut pas prendre
le chiffre tel qu'il est sans penser à
comment notre société a évolué avec ses
chiffres depuis 30 ans bruno justine
éléments qu'on n'a pas pris en compte et
même temps c'est que laurence vous le
savez c'est les échéances politiques qui
arrivent présidentielle et c'est donc
c'est un seul est montée crescendo
même si ça existe attention je ne dis
pas qu'ils aient preview est ce que est
ce que est ce que ça c'est une vraie
problématique façon expresse de faire
monter changement national ces
ministères et bien sûr le rassemblement
national chikoti toute la clique m
intéresse en voie d'atteindre ce que
vous êtes en train de dire non au
pouvoir c'est que vous dites que le
gouvernement actuel
peut-être fait monter en sauce tout ça a
fait monter la sauce de ça pour faire
monter le rassemblement national pour
espérer le faire de la politique ça dure
qu'une fille danser sur question du
ministère ces officiers la sécu
ça n'empêche que donne pendant les
échéances électorales à chaque fois au
met au devant de la scène et là c'est
vrai une violence qui s est vrai alors
il ya un truc qui est vrai